are you do with a rim Amenia Ren and who
might you be
James Fleshman I'm a meteorologist
I believe the weather can be predicted I
need you and your balloon to help me
women don't belong in Veloz on show this
is absurd your reputation is built on
paper and my reputation is built on
screens
I hate you going up in that balloon I do
not wish to lose you to any more
foolishness it's where I have found the
greatest happiness the possibility of
weather prediction could save lives we
are scientists but fortune tellers you
are the only person who could fly us
higher than anyone has ever been
[Music]
and so it begins
[Music]
have you noticed it's completely silent
[Music]
[Applause]
there's nothing more beautiful of the
stars of the sky we are dancing among
something you should think of slowing
you know
every there there we are traveling into
an unknown one that we to lose and ice
is gonna be more important than our
lives
and will come a time when we going to
crap
that decision will only be mine yes I
have a feeling they're not coming back
we took to the skies to change the world
you don't change the world simply by
looking at it proven wrong Jax you
change it by living in it together
report the Stars closer
[Music]
you